je suis lorraine je vis dans une région
à trois frontières avec l'allemagne le
luxembourg et la belgique
c'est un territoire comme vous le savez
profondément marquée par les guerres et
je mesure la chance d'appartenir à la
première génération qui a grandi dans la
paix grâce à l'union européenne à
laquelle je suis profondément attaché
cette europe pour nos enfants les
générations futures
je veux la protéger préserver son
identité sa culture ses racines
judéo-chrétiennes
voilà pourquoi nous devons stopper tout
élargissement est arrêtée définitivement
le processus d'adhésion de la turquie
qui n'a rien à faire dans l'union
européenne
voilà pourquoi aussi je n'accepte pas la
lâcheté de nos dirigeants face à la
vague d'immigration illégale et que nous
subissons par son laxisme coupable
emmanuel macron à le président
responsable d'une augmentation
historique des demandes d'asile en
france
il dépense chaque année des milliards
d'euros pour les clandestins mais
matraque nous retraités d'impôts nous
nous voulons ramener systématiquement
les bateaux de migrants sur les côtes
africaines pour sauver des vies stoppez
les filières mafieuses de paix soeur
mais aussi responsabiliser l'union
africaine qui ne peut se contenter de
recevoir des milliards d'euros de
l'union européenne sans contribuer à la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
de ces populations et en particulier de
sa jeunesse
je rappelle que l'union européenne et
ses états membres versent chaque année
17 milliards d'euros pour le
développement de l'afrique
les européens n'ont pas à payer deux
fois pour le développement et pour les
clandestins sur notre sol nous
conditionneront les aides au
développement et les visas pour les pays
d'afrique du moyen orient ou d'asie aux
résultats réels en matière de maîtrise
de leur immigration est une coopération
efficace au retour de leurs
ressortissants
arrivés illégalement sur notre continent
enfin pour lutter contre le dévoiement
de l'asile les demandes d'asile devons
traiter en dehors de nos frontières dans
des centres d'études de l'asile et non
chez nous en europe comme le veut
emmanuel macron alors le 26 mai prochain
un seul jour un seul tour n'oubliez pas
c'est jour de la fête des mères
voter massivement pour la liste conduite
par françois xavier bellamy et tous
ensemble nous pourrons construire bâtir
et avoir cette europe que nous voulons
une europe qui nous protègera